and there's always that first
10 minutes that's like smelling a dead
fish or walking into a monkey house and
then something will click a little tiny
bit and that leads to something else you
force yourself to get going
one sentence two sentences three
and little by little you enter that
other world and you hit this kind of uh
escape velocity you're gone the world
the normal
mundane
sort of stupid world all that's gone
horror fiction a lot of it to me is the
lure of the forbidden
one of the things that i've tried to do
is to keep my imagination
young
i think that producers and filmmakers
look for visual imagery they look for
simple stories simple bright stories
with high conflict but i think that
they're also seduced by visual imagery
well i think you ought to read a lot and
i think you ought to write a lot and i
mean you have to write in order to
develop a style to create a style of
your own and when it comes to the
reading part of it there's a magic
moment a really magic moment if you read
enough they will always come to you if
you want to be a
writer
where you put down some book and say
this
really sucks
i can do better than this
you're saying to somebody
come with me and i will say things to
you that nobody else will say
[Music]
[Music]
but what is it that grabs an audience at
the first level
forbidden someone is forbidden so
you're saying to somebody
come with me and i will say things to
you that nobody else will say
and i will show you things that nobody
else does it's so horrible to imagine
that's right
and again it shares the same attraction
as comedy a movie that's really funny
that really makes people laugh is
generally saying i'm going to show you
something that you haven't seen before
so that when mel brooks did blazing
sandals back in 74 or whatever it was
and the cowboys eat beans and then sit
around the fire and they start to fart
right well nobody had ever heard anybody
actually fart in a movie and we all fell
on the floor laughing you know it made
that movie
so it was something that had been
previously forbidden you know we all
know about it we all know that people
pass gas but nobody had ever put it on
the big screen and here what are you
doing it's forbidden well for instance
in
pet cemetery
what i said was
here's something that we don't talk
about people sometimes have kids who die
there are terrible things that happen
and sometimes the child will die young
and in pet cemetery that happened and i
followed the family through the grieving
process and then
the father goes out to the graveyard and
digs his son up and tries to bring him
back to life and the important part
about it you know i i like to say that
fiction is a lie but good fiction is the
truth inside the lie and the truth that
any person who's ever lost a child knows
is that
you wish you could bring them back to
life and the story explores what might
happen if something like that could
could happen so horror fiction a lot of
it to me is the lure of the forbidden
the best description of writing a novel
that i ever heard
it's actually in
thomas williams's book
the hair of harold roo but he says that
writing a novel is like building a
little campfire on an empty dark plane
and one by one
these characters come out of the dark
and each one has a little pile of wood
and they put it on the fire and if
you're very lucky before the fire goes
out it's this big bonfire and all the
characters stand around it and warm
themselves
and that's the way it's always been for
me his father a merchant seaman skipped
out when stephen was only two
he has no memory of him
but he left
that box a box in the attic
that would change his life
there were
like cocktail napkins from
tokyo
little hula hula dolls from somewhere in
the south pacific there were those
things but there was also an hp
lovecraft book and it showed this
horrible green monster
rising from a broken open grave in a
graveyard and i thought
this is it you know whatever it is
something
chimes in you and you say
i found
something
that resonates with my soul one of the
things
that i've tried to do
is to keep
my imagination
young
what kind of books do you write
well
if you ask the ordinary
run-of-the-mill reader if there is such
a guy or such a gal i guess that i write
uh
horror novels i think that what i
actually write are suspense novels
what's the difference
i think that
the purpose of the horror novel is to
sort of
gross you out my idea of it is and i'm
not averse to this i will do this it's
part of the fun of it is it's kind of uh
at the it's a childish thing the way the
humor is the two things are closely
allied they both elicit when they work
to their best of a vocal reaction from
the audience laughter if it's comedy and
a a scream or a yell if it's if it's
horror but it's they're both childish
and uh it's kind of like uh
when you're a kid and you're sitting at
the dining room table and you want to
get to your to your sister or your
brother you kind of chew up your food
and then ah you hang your mouth open
like that that's horror suspense is a
little more high class than that so
maybe that's why my mother used to say
that was tasteless that's tasteless yeah
that's right well my mother when i was a
kid used to say stephen your taste is
all in your mouth
and that's true but it has made me
relatively wealthy i don't think that
you find them exactly i think that what
you do is you keep your sensors open
and it's
the more that you do the job the more
you come
to
understand in a kind of intuitive way
that you're always
you know your radar is on and the thing
is going around and around and around
and it's not picking up any blips and
then
something will happen and it will click
and you'll say
this is this is an idea for a story and
for me
uh i'm usually working on something so
that's kind of got to go to the end of
the line and the best thing about that
is is that the bad ideas kind of just
drop out of the mix you forget about
them the good ones stick around so
anyway i had a honda because i didn't
know any better and uh
and i got it out in the spring when the
snow was gone from maine and i started
it up and it just it wasn't right it
just wasn't running right
and uh somebody told me well you go on
up to this guy's farm
he's got a uh you probably know where
this is going
he said go on up this guy's got a little
garage adjacent to his farm and he's got
this unique way of doing things he tells
you what it's going to cost and that's
what it costs
so i went up and about halfway to this
farm which was way out in east overshoe
the um
the motor started to skip
and uh by the time i got to the farm
it was barely running at all and it died
as i pulled into the
into the guy's door yard that's what we
call in maine a door yard
so
i'm on my motorcycle and the motorcycle
was dead
and from this garage
came the biggest goddamn saint bernard
you ever saw in your life
and the guy came out the mechanic came
out and the dogs going
and it's got that stuff coming out of
his eyes you know the way that saint
bernards do
and he said
don't worry
buster is very friendly and buster
weighed about 250 pounds and so i walked
over toward buster and his haunches just
sort of coiled down and his teeth came
out and he actually started to go for me
and the guy brought a socket wrench down
on his hind end
and
the dog sat still
and
i thought i might get an apology but the
guy looked at me and just said buster
must not light your face
so he fixed my motorcycle and i wrote a
book called cujo
and uh
and it worked out yeah why do you think
yours have translated to film so well i
think that producers and filmmakers look
for visual imagery they look for simple
stories simple bright stories with high
conflict but i think that they're also
seduced by visual imagery and
my books are visual because i grew up on
tv i grew up on the movies and i also
grew up on images poetry this is the ts
emily and ezra pal do you write every
day
yeah
which includes today
yeah you wrote today i did i'm glad we
didn't interrupt where in the cycle are
you of book production well i i finished
a novel and uh i am letting it
marinate a little bit you have to get
away from it a little while it's too
easy if you finish something and go
right back into it to either say
this is terrible or
what's even worse to say my i really
wrote a good job this is great i'll
probably win the pulitzer prize
for this i started to send stories out
and uh
and i pounded a nail into the wall of my
bedroom and when i got the rejection
slips back i would
put them on that nail and by the time
that i was 16 or 17 years old
the nail tore free from the plaster so i
just got a bigger nail and i thought
when i wrote the shining i said this
wonderful idea about this family in this
haunted hotel and what they really want
is the boy with psychic powers and at
the end of the book the hotel will kind
of absorb him and then we'll see the
next year we'll see the whole family as
ghosts but
it didn't turn out that way i i feel
like you have to follow
the characters and you have to follow
the story where it leads and the last
thing that i want to do is to spoil a
book with plot
so
you know
i think i think the plot that plot is
the last resort of bad writers is a rule
i'm a lot more interested in character
and situation and you'll follow it where
it goes and the way that that the way
that i work uh i try to get out there
and i try to get six pages a day so with
a book like end of watch and i work when
i'm working i work every day
three four hours and i try to get those
six pages and i try to get them fairly
clean so if the manuscript is
let's say
360 pages long that's basically two
months work it's concentrated but it's a
fairly
but that's assuming that it goes well
and you do hit six pages a day i usually
do you force yourself to get going
one sentence two sentences three
and little by little you enter that
other world
yes
i was just wondering what advice would
give young people who are considering
careers as writers
[Music]
well i think you ought to read a lot and
i think you ought to write a lot and
those are really the two major things
you can't put it off
you have to uh
you have to really do the work you have
to be you have to be well read i don't
have any patience with people who say oh
man i want to be a writer but i don't
have time to read but if you don't have
time to read
you can't be a writer you've got to read
just about everything
so i think that's the most important
thing and then you have to
you have to read
and i mean you have to write in order to
develop a style to create a style of
your own and when it comes to the
reading part of it there's a magic
moment a really magic moment if you read
enough they will always come to you if
you want to be a
writer
where you put down some book and say
this
really sucks
i
to develop as a writer you must be
reading books constantly here are a few
suggestions
the shining
carry
salem's lot
pet cemetery dolores claiborne the green
mile
under the dome
you get the idea people will say do you
keep a notebook and the answer is
i think a writer's notebook is the best
way in the world to immortalize bad
ideas
uh my idea about a good idea is one that
sticks around and sticks around and
sticks around it's like to me it's like
if you were to put breadcrumbs in a
strainer and shake it which is what the
passage of time is for me it's like
shaking a strainer all this
stuff that's not very big and not very
important just kind of dissolves and
falls out
but the good stuff stays you know the
big pieces stay
i had the idea for under the dome
uh when i was teaching high school back
in 1973 and it was just too big for me
and i was too young for it
and i wrote about 25 26 pages
and put it away so
the good stuff stays so does that does
that mean that writing can be
taught
can be learned
it can be learned but i'm not sure it
can be taught it's a self-taught kind of
thing i think the the best writers are
are voracious readers
who pick up
the cadences and the feel of
narration through a number of different
books and you begin by maybe copying the
style of writers that really knocked you
out
uh i mean as a teenager
i read a lot of
lovecraft so i wrote like hp lovecraft
and in my 20s i read a lot of uh ross
mcdonald and raymond chandler so i wrote
like those guys but little my little you
develop your own
style and i have a routine because i
think that writing is self-hypnosis and
you fall into a
a kind of a trance if you do the same
passes
over and over so i'll get up
have some breakfast with my wife watch
cnn and then i'll make my pot of tea
and sit down and write for about three
and a half hours i started with short
stories when i was 18
sold my first one when i was about 20.
the short stories were making money and
i got very comfortable with that format
and i've never wanted to leave it
completely behind and what happens to me
a lot of times is i will start out
saying this would be a terrific
short story idea and it balloons and
becomes a novel
misery started as a short story
and gerald's game started as a short
story those were things that i thought
would be
small
and grew to a size where they would be a
novel and i also think that
that
what happens when you sleep
is your
screen is refreshed it's like by the end
of the day you ever noticed if you leave
your computer on after a while to save
energy or something the screen darkens
but if you move the cursor around it
immediately brightens up again it kind
of refreshes itself
i think that when you sleep
the very dreaming process i'm just
guessing now hey this is all just
speculation but i do think that sleeping
refreshes the process but yeah i've had
a few ideas in my sleep for a long time
i felt like
movies were a
medium because it's like skating it's
all on the surface
every now and then some movie will be
reduced to doing a voice over you know
where this character is talk and i can
just kind of get the interior life yeah
and i just kind of go no no no you've
clearly mistaken this medium for
something that it's not
but i came to realize that films have a
language of their own
and you have to learn that language and
it isn't enough to say well i've watched
movies my whole life you have to write a
couple but the thing is you learn you
learn little by little so do you
release books differently now than used
to in that like do you have a different
definition of what a successful book is
or where on the eve of a book's release
to you
pay special kind of attention to how it
will be received or how it's being
reviewed
i think that if you spend too much time
worrying about what the audience is
going to like that they're not going to
like anything that you do i just
look for ideas that i really enjoy
something that i really want to live
with for a while i like the story about
the people under the dome
and
i get into it most of the time and then
i just have a ball i never finished a
book and felt like i'm glad that's done
i usually finish a book and say geez i
don't want to say goodbye to these
people and if the people who read it
feel the same way then then i'm really
happy
all i know is that i sit down and i turn
on the machine and there's always that
first
10 minutes that's like smelling a dead
fish or walking into a monkey house and
then something will click a little tiny
bit and that leads to something else and
it's like
until it's going faster and faster and
then you hit this kind of uh
escape velocity you're gone
the world
the normal
mundane
sort of stupid world
where you got to do the breakfast dishes
and you got to make the beds you know
and you got to worry about getting the
kid to the dentist all that's gone
you